في ختام قمه مجموعه ال 20 للاقتصادات
الكبرى في جزيره بالي باندونيسيا هيمنت
ثلاث محاور رئيسيه الصحه العالميه وتحول
الرقمي والانتقال نحو الطاقه المستدامه
الاقل تاثيرا على المناخ في صوره قاده
مجموعه ال 20 وهم يقومون بغرس شجيرات في
فضاء اخضر قبل نهايه القمه لكن الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا وتطوراتها المستمره
ما زالت في واجهه الحدث العالمي
من الهجمات الوحشيه في اوكرانيا
مهما طال الوقت وسنظل متحدين
زعماء المجموعه رحبوا بمبادله البحر
الاسود للحبوب التي تلعب فيها تركيا دورا
محوريه
بصفقه الحبوب لقد بقي اكثر من 10 ملايين
بمجرد عوده ساتصل مع السيد بوتين وسنناقش
قضايا الاسمده ونعمل على تمديد صفقه
الحبوب لمده عامه
انهم يدركون دورهم القيادي في الالتزام
الثابت لتحقيق هدف اتفاقيه الامم المتحده
بشان تغير المناخ من اجل تصدي لاثار
التغيرات المناخيه في العالم لكن الالتزام
بالمناخ مرهون بسرعه الانتقال من القول
الى الفعل كما يقول الخبراء وبما يفرضه
الاقتصاد العالمي في حقبه الازمات
والنزاعات